signs of the times
students protesting in westminster again
today
angry and confused by an a-level appeals
process
that still seems far from clear now we
have to wait for an appeals process that
they've just revoked after
two hours of them publishing it the
uncertainty that we have no idea where
our future is going to go
whether we're going to be able to get
even a degree at the uni we want to
there's no safety net this thread three
triple lock
is not a safety net at all the appeals
process has evolved over the last week
one day before results were announced
students in england were told they could
appeal
using a valid mock exam then at 5 pm
yesterday
the exam's regulator in england
published guidance on the process
that was then endorsed by the government
before being withdrawn late last night
and placed under review students here
say that guidance represented another
broken promise by the government
as it stopped a mock result being used
if it was higher than the school
assessed grade
it's sudden withdrawal though has added
to the sense of confusion around the
appeals process
and an impression that the government
isn't in control
and that's starting to worry
conservative mps speaking to sky news
the tory chair of the education
committee said the government may have
to look at pausing the publication
of gcse results next week or even doing
a full u-turn if they can't get the
appeals system right then
we may have to go down the scottish
option in terms
of recognizing teachers predicted grades
but i very much hope
that a proper fair appeal system is
simple that people
can understand that is fair and that
gets young people back on that
education ladder of opportunity and with
silence from downing street this weekend
labour has called on boris johnson to
take control
now's a really important time for these
young people and they deserve better
than what they've got currently
and boris johnson the prime minister
needs to come to the country and speak
to these young people and tell him how
he's going to fix this mess they've
created
lena also wants answers after she lost
her place
at the london school of economics llc
has been like the dream uni for me
i was you don't know how excited i was
to get the offer
she's now taking legal action to
challenge the algorithm that downgraded
her i want to fight for it because i
feel like my grades
aren't reflective of all the effort i
put in at gcse in my marks in my as
levels
throughout the year um and there's no
real justice in what they've decided to
award me
more protests in cardiff today as the
uk's children's commissioners say the
system
has thrown up too many anomalies and led
to inequalities between the four nations
concerning all corners of the country
that who you are
looks to matter more than what you do